donges accueille deux grands artistes de
grands gagnants de l'adisq
hier et mercredi derniers alexandra
stréliski bonsoir et michel rivard
bonsoir ont chacun trois trois félix
cette belle statuette félix alors on va
en parler mais et pour vous comme
créateur d'abord c'est important la
reconnaissance d'avoir d'être reconnu
par les pairs mais aussi par le public
alexandra qui vous vu comme un conte de
fées si d'une certaine manière la
question si c'est si important la
reconnaissance ouais ben oui je pense
qu'on vivrait pas comme un artiste si on
n'avait pas le soutien de soutien des
gens plus la visibilité parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on fait connaître notre
notre métier pinottes notre produit
artistique on qu on aura connu
aujourd'hui que vous aviez faire des
plus beaux témoignages revendre recevoir
votre félix parce que dans le fond la
création vous a permis de revivre de
poursuivre de retrouver tout ce que
j'ose dire le bonheur mais en tout cas
un élan dans la vie que la vie est belle
et vaut la peine d'être vécue
absolument oui moi j'en ai souvent parlé
mais j'ai écrit mon album dans une
période assez assez trouble puis je m'en
suis sorti j'ai trouvé ma place en fait
si je trouvais plus ma place dans le
monde
je les trouvais en affrontant ma peur de
monter sur scène et de présenter mais
mes pièces plus aujourd'hui j'en suis là
donc j'avais envie de donner un petit
message d'espoir aussi fière parce que
je pense que c'est bien de continuer
leurs cris boumsong serait très beau
message est tellement qu'on peut le
soutien avec vichy je pense que vous
c'est 60 millions des coutures spotify
quarante mille albums vendus d'un script
donc ça veut dire c'est le disque d'or
donc s'inscrire dans j'en suis très fier
de ça
le plein de dates à venir michel rivard
vous vaut aussi la création parce que
bon je vais quand même le montrer
l'origine de mes espèce très beau et
vous l'avez sorti en vinyle aussi un
déni imposé sortir des vinyles comme
quoi les traditions ça con mais c'est
une tradition chaque et moi ça fait
partie un peu de mon de ma façon à moi
en tant que consommateur de musique
deux pas de résister entendons nous
comptons déjà dans son voyage c'est bien
ça se tiendrait bien comme ces
plateformes l'or existent et qu'elles
sont je trouve d'une inutilité
extraordinaire moi personnellement je
suis abonné à un peu de musique
je paie 10 dollars par mois ce que pour
un homme je sais qu'au bout de la ligne
les créateurs ne sont pas rémunérés
comme ils le devraient ça je sais et
c'est ça le problème à régler et c'est
là qu'on a besoin de l'aide des
gouvernements on a besoin que les gens
ce qu'ils ont à mettre leurs culottes
pour vraiment affronter les
multinationales sur ce point là avec les
impôts et tout ça je suis totalement
d'accord mais moi en tant que
consommateur de musique j'adore cette
plateforme là parce que on est autour
d'une table avec mes enfants avec des
amis on ne connaît pas ce regard-là très
en deçà n'importe quoi n'importe où dans
classique dans le moderne contemporain
dedans toute l'ailé les formes la
musique et moi ce que je fais c'est que
je lis régulièrement les nouvelles
parutions l'éleveur loges et
naturellement je les écoute sur la
plateforme et quand j'aime ça je vais
acheter un dîner je trouve que c'est ça
qui est fantastique c'est qu'on peut
écouter s'imprégner quelque chose puis
quand on aime vraiment ce que l'on
encourage l'artiste et henri idéal ce
serait que l'artiste vous êtes justement
rémunérés dès le départ parce que vous
avez vécu les deux époques l2 j'ai vu
plus de vos images
les grosses vendredi
et qu'on calcule est à terme d'objets
physiques groupe en plus alors que vous
alexandra vous apportez d'une nouvelle
génération consciente et hier elle a dit
ce que tout une relève des jeunes
artistes qui explosent et dans le fond
c'est plate forme lance une forme de
démocratie ou si ça rend accessible
l'art la création sur moi c'est moi sur
les plates formes de distribution de
streaming je n'existerais pas forcément
donc c'est sûr que mais comme je disais
tout à l'heure je peux pas me prendre
comme exemple pour dire vive le
streaming parce que la cause me dépasse
bien largement est ce qu a dit pierre
hier c'est que les gouvernements doivent
faire quelque chose pour protéger un
marché au marché local soit dit en
passant on n'est pas les seuls à avoir
ce problème là je pense que c'est un
problème international
et c'est sûr que les gouvernements
doivent protéger doivent protéger la
société et nous protéger les gens des
commerçants les artisans c'est leur job
qui le fait normal de payer des impôts
on s'entend tous nationaux et sait et
c'est normal aussi pour le
le consommateur de payer pour le musée
magnin
je pense que beaucoup de gens qui pour
qui bon à partir du moment où maintenant
est là et puis on se retrouve sur les
plates formes seront les artistes vivent
très bien on est leur musique joue tout
le temps
bon c'est pas vrai c'est plus vrai
maintenant du tout alors il faut c'est
là qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut
régler le problème parce que
l'accessibilité c'est extraordinaire et
c'est formidable d'avoir au bout de son
téléphone et je parle pas juste de
musique là je viens vous décidez d'aller
voir les étoiles du prado peut y aller
avec votre téléphone puis faire le tour
du musée
c'est absolument fabuleux d'avoir toute
la culture du monde de toutes les
époques disponibles et facilement
accessible
vous seriez vous alexandra que vous
c'est une révélation d'autant que cette
révélation de l'année en plus de l'album
de l'année + bond de 3,3 bosser comme
toute une carrière qui s'installe en
proie au trio un beau un beau trio donc
direz vous que le fait de de votre genre
musical qui a sa place et du piano que
ça que les plateformes vous rendre
davantage accessible à cause parce que
c'était de la musique et non pas soluble
et non pas des chansons aussi
oui assurément c'est sûr mais moi je moi
dans mon style de musique et il ya
énormément de playlists et en fait c'est
ce qui amène autant de ces décès les
playlists et il y en a beaucoup et comme
c'est une musique qui n'a pas de mot qui
n'a pas de langue c'est sa danse à
travers ses frontières mais encore une
fois je suis pas le meilleur exemple
parce que il s'agit pas de mon histoire
à moi et s'il s'agit de l'histoire des
gens qui chantent en français on est né
des producteurs locaux
tout ça et c'est ça c'est ça qu'il faut
sauver ça c'est ça qu'il faut protéger
et pour vous et michel cette
transformation elle était encore sous le
choc c'est sûr que quand on regarde les
commandes comme ali vente d'objets
physiques ont baissé c'est cpie - je
viens d'une génération vient d'une
époque où l'objet physique était
important c'est pour ça que j'aime les
livres ou les pour ça que j'ai fait un
livre disque premièrement parce que
j'adore les livres aussi puis je voulais
le texte de la pièce soit avec le disque
et le vinyle
moi je moi je suis revenu au vinyle une
dizaine d'années est pas une seule des
six qui se vend le plus
proportionnellement aux vinyles d'année
en année reprend du service pour quoi
parce qu'on entre les mains des l'objet
on entre les mains quelque chose qu'il
faut il faut faire le geste de le sortir
d'enfer effet folie faire attention faut
l'écouter leur virée de côté après tout
ça et moi je viens cette époque là alors
c'est sûr que plus plus la musique
devenait impalpable il a fallu que je
m'adapte
hier ce qui m'a impressionné par ce que
leur mandat par le bonheur d'avoir gagné
ses six statuettes tous les trois pour
les deux mais trois souhaits de chacun
vous avez attendait jeudi remerciements
faire avec un générique incroyable way a
généré que javier les créateurs a jugé
insensé tas de reconnaissance c'est que
c'est pas vrai qu'on monte sur la scène
avec sa guitare puisqu'on bon spectacle
une reconnaissance et un sous sol où je
suis bon joie et un musicien mais je
parle déjà chante tout se vend dans une
rue marcadet vous avez des conseillers
vous a dégagé des conseillers j'ai des
créateurs et hier d'oise et que je me
suis permis de
mon droit d'aînesse commence à parler et
là j'ai entendu la petite musique que
j'ai fait non je m'excuse arrêté dans
votre musique
j'ai déjà remercié c'est du travail
d'équipé c'est important - parce que ça
permet au public de prendre connaissance
de l'ampleur du travail qu'il ya
derrière la création syrienne pour vous
allez jouer les gens croient qu'on roule
sur l'or ils viennent voir ils ont payé
tant pour leurs billets la salle est
pleine je suis tout seul sur son oeil
je marchais avec le moteur c'est pas
vrai c'est important de dire meilleur
vous avez dit cela quoi 66 67 ans de
travail suite à 66 ans quand j'ai
commencé à l'écrire avec ces personnes
mais il reste que c'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de travail oui et
créer c'est aussi pour vous aussi j'ai
beaucoup travaillé la vie d'un artiste
c'est beaucoup de travail c'est ce qu'on
voit c'est la pointe de l'iceberg mais
on travaille tous est on est on est tous
sur un peu entrepreneurs aussi c'est
sale c'est un aspect qu'on oublie t
aujourd'hui est un artiste justement
avec toutes ces problématiques c'est la
diversification des sources de revenus
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à survivre
c'est les faire beaucoup de choses
il faut s'investir dans plein plein
plein plein plein de choses puis et puis
on travaille on travaille très fort
alors ils ont fait la création ensuite
tu la diffusion si c'est tout essayé de
garder sa ligne
artistique dans tout dans les modes de
communication dans les produits dérivés
dans cette structure c'est parce que je
parlais un peu de briser le mètre
l'oeuvre de l'artiste intouchables qui
se lèvent le matin avec la plume au coin
de la bouche cuisine de quoi je parle je
compose d'un univers je pense de public
la création pure oui oui parce que si ce
tracé très différents mais c'est vrai
que c'est bizarre semble pas ça
ressemble pas du tout à ça c'est
justement de très investi puis avant oui
je faisais de la musique plus appliqués
que j'avais des commandes très clair
puisse-t-elle phone 7 des siens super
exercice de création en fait ça nous
donne un cadre puis dans les cartes des
fois on est très créatif c'est mais
laissez votre cadre de l'année liszt
séance d'examen visez-vous qu'on entend
quand on écoute
ouais absolue l'autre qu'est ce que vous
avez l'impression d'avoir en commun tous
les deux mettez-moi moyenne en fait je
trouve que depuis hier on a quelque
chose en commun c'est que hier l'adisq a
récompensé un spectacle atypique qui est
plus théâtral que musical qui prend un
tour de chant qui est vraiment un objet
théâtral de théâtre musical et ils ont
récompensé une femme extraordinaire qui
fait de la musique instrumentale avec
juste un piano et à travers le paysage
actuel où on se surenchère d'imagés de
sons et de production est toujours
agressé par de la musique de la pub il
ya toujours deux que nos deux univers
était honoré moi ça me touche beaucoup
et je me sens très bien quoi exactement
c'est très doux vous parlez de douceur
mais elle aussi c'est très doux des fois
ce fort sur les notes basses
c'est vraiment la douceur c'est très
beau ce que tu as dit ap
ils m'ont aussi je travaille dans la
douceur et dans la dans la subtilité
puis je tends content que nos travaux
étaient reconnus alors comme le veut la
tradition elle a dit j'ai toujours aimé
me dans la salle monsieur rodriguez qui
était comme dans 83 le ministre comme on
l'a vite était pas disponible mais je
pense que des voix vont se faire
entendre pour que maintenant je pense
que la même personne de pierre lapointe
on est très clair très articulé une
chaire avoir encore une fois
félicitations
ophélie très beau date de novembre à
décembre chez jean douchet partout aussi
chanté des pages et des pages de date
pour les deux juste à les regarder sur
les sommets parce que l'alternative le
spectacle est une belle oui ça c'est sûr
mais normaliser la xsara
c'est là que les classements merci avec
100 brasse félicitations mais hommage à
tous les deux merci mon job chez a très
bien